始めヤンキーてくれ関係で行くと度合いも
の笑顔総括ぞ
まずですかー
生きてたら見ますドイツをはじめそうです
これまで数々の地域を起こしてきた衝撃の
問題商品今日ついに収集がありますこちら
ぺー案が焼きそば国激辛ファイナルをにが
もう泣きながらばってんとします5奥激辛
のからさんに by だけでほどから2月
ので小さなお子様や管理が苦手な方の口ば
十分にご注意ください
フェア無関係水に
終わります
なかった僕んペヤング焼きそば大好きなん
ですよ昔ならずーっとずーっと長い歴史
啓発や貴様の新作が出るたびに食べ動画に
して食べて動画にしてある日を支えて
ブランクさんがちょっと方向性を変えてき
たというかかないから行かないから会に
すべてを全振りしだして上でも俺はフェア
具についていくそそう思って激辛シーズ
出るためてるだけ食べてたんですけども
もう良いよファイナルということで最後
ですもうこの国激辛から良いペアんべ
シリーズに収集が打たれました最後の商品
だと思いたいね歳の手術とリターンズとか
マジで見てください6です起こります今回
のコレ何がすごいかっていうと国激辛のか
なそまで by なんですよ6で先に行っ
てきます無理ですねだったって本当に絶対
無理
ワッっていつかの動画で僕もごめんなさい
かなりの無理です食べませんと言ったん
ですけどもまぁ最後なんでしょ批判がエサ
が最後って言うんだったら僕食べます+裏
で卒業式だけよさすがにお葬式がいきます
よ最後なんだろ
迎える4歳割ったら俺はもう暑い合わせて
もらう之屋さんご存知の通りあの僕辛さ
耐性が本当にゼロでかなりの抹茶9無理な
んですよ玉でぜひ動くべきからファイナル
食べる何かの基準になればいいかな通って
超辛いのが苦手な男が食べるとどうなるか
を皆さんにお見せしたいと思いますね
ロシアの部活の試合前の緊張感があって
ケッこう怖いんですけどもなんでこんなの
作りましたかと壁 anne さんも感銘
してくださいとか色々言ってきたんです
けど最後貼ったら cocco 強く以降
だとありがとう激辛シリーズ楽しくは
なかったけどいい思い出にはなったし素敵
な動画が誰か生まれてきましたその覚えで
も全てまとめて空をさせて頂きたいと今日
は思っております
バイバイなんてちょっと笑顔でしっかり
食べていこうと思います出会い校
神食べ方
須玖北激辛ファイル作っていこうと思い
ます yeah早く
したああああとってもかわいい袋が出てき
たね早くを入れてレット投入を蛇ちゃん
まで書
3分たちましたニコニコさっすこういう
切ってこようと思います
[音楽]
ああ
そこでやるしっかり切れないと辛さの
シーンが伝わらないかなこれが限界まで
見つけるようやってきました
goo
しよしよしではそうそう入れていきマース
だんだんだんだんなランラン何かた順番
ですか
いやば間近
いきます前
あまなぶん
なんだなんだな
うん全部し限りさせてもらいましただ
ノーコン中身もはーい受け取るぞっっああ
落ちなくています始めしっかり混ぜな
ディスプレイもでしょうーうーうーすごい
うわあああっ
名前も顔も使わ近づけられないやばい
はぁ万全ありました
go 色ですねまあ金とってもおいしい
そうの療育早速準備ができたということで
食べてみようと思います
はきまーおいしそうだなぁ
あちょっと無駄だこれ
ぷくえぐーん
[拍手]
ちょっちょっとはーい
うわぁ
わー
ああああああああ
ああ
ああああああ
はっ
はー
ni
[笑い]
voodoo
car
ところん
[音楽]
ハハハああ
ああああああ
ブーバーっっ
はnao
それは不明
ちょ靴それね
痛みとかそれを民痛みパフ富ナポリタン
ですよ
ウバか誰かそんなマッチするものじゃない
これ
行ってきた
見て鳥肌見える見えます何言っ
8位とかじゃなかったなう
何持ってないん
第4
ねっ1人ねー
[音楽]
結構客大丈夫あっはい
全部みたいな口なかった
なぁおっおおっ
ないジョブインそこで終わっ
ファイターですよ
[音楽]
俺も歳だっ
see
猿ニーデイ
[音楽]
それを
洗うと
ラーメン屋さんじゃん
これやばいやばい5キャリングも切り捨て
地をしっかりようには炎市主催し残さない
のでやばいよ
なった
うおっぱげっぱわぽわって言ってる場合上
くって言ってくれ
口やバジャントっ
ああああああ本土で強いこれ
[笑い]
滑ってうまくなくしておる
me
[音楽]
4来てくスッと言いたいんだ
涙でおいたいっ
ここが光った
me
4 n
[音楽]
半分が葉
まあ良いところではー
[音楽]
ガードだわー
[拍手]
ua どうですかいやー
[音楽]
無理でした今水切りして普通のペンが
ソースたしてようやく激辛ペヤングねこれ
でも辛い人苦手な人は無理なレベルです
ちょっと
やはり者向きだしてもいいんだよもう必ず
食わせて頂きますのでちょっとくってみる
これどう多くを釣ってみたいですか洗って
ベッドのソースを入れてもらうんですそう
いただきますどうぞ
[音楽]
あっ話オレがおかしいわけじゃないよね
はぁはぁああっ
はっはっはきちんとう
ターンたーーー
別の飛びもねさすがに空野菜はさすがよね
でもこれでも辛いが本当におかしいあった
よねでもこうなる焼きそばっていうのが
激辛とのコンビネーションが貼る意味で
よくてい
から v
調整官民人くらいからん言えばいけばなら
ないよねー
びっくりだよ
[音楽]
福よ
ん
[音楽]
ふわぁ
これでもまだ触れなぁ
あああ
はああああ
[音楽]
まあもうつもう行け行け
ええええええ
[音楽]
car
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
あーためおりましてほしい完食です
これは無理です皆さんのその辛さに対する
耐性がと陸なるか分かりませんが僕みたい
に金の全くないと本当に不可能それを皆
さんに伝えたかった後はの水洗いして
マヨネーズかけて来とめちゃくちゃか
なかったしそれでやって激辛ペヤング街の
からでしたでも
これで最後なんでしょ結局ピングさ
今までありがとうございました
ばいばい
[音楽]
blh re j